pour une démonstration il a testé l'idée
d'un conseiller municipal donné à un
citoyen dénonciateur 25% du montant de
la contravention pour les véhicules
stationnés dans les pistes cyclables des
blocages que l'on constate fréquemment
sur les pistes montréalaises aujourd'hui
j'en ai eu quatre cinq à devoir
contourner
ou on fait autre chose avec plus de 1000
constats d'infraction à 173 dollars
depuis le 1er mai Montréal serre la vie
SAU contrevenants
est-ce qu'on pourrait imiter New York et
payer les citoyens je suis pas persuadé
que dans la culture de la Ville de
Montréal la dénonciation pour des
compréhensions pour avoir une
rémunération que ça soit quelque chose
qui soit aujourd'hui dans l'esprit des
gens ah ouais ouais c'est une bonne idée
pour moi
je serais pas contre super idée super
idée on devrait faire ça ici pendant ces
trois heures de chasse au délinquant
notre testeur new-yorkais aurait pu
récolter 350 dollars Vélo Québec ici et
plutôt réticent sont toujours un peu
créatifs mais ça reste avant tout une
responsabilité des autorités compétentes
demandées aux citoyens de jouer à la
police là c'est pas une bonne idée pour
pour plein de raisons la Ville de
Montréal ne rejette pas complètement la
proposition
mais
intéressante c'est compliqué de me
prononcer parce que ce genre de mise en
oeuvre là c'est ça des incidences
juridiques ça c'est bon c'est ça demeure
complexe à mettre en place donc je suis
une idée intéressante mais je pense pas
qu'on en est là pour l'instant comme
cette cycliste pas trop séduite par
l'idée
ici Mathieu Prost Radio-Canada Montréal